all right how's it going everyone doing
well not too enthusiastic okay so yeah
today we're gonna be talking about web
standards this is my first time using a
clicker so bear with me here the talk is
called Hitchhiker's Guide to web
standards and to kick things off I'd
like to introduce myself my name is DOM
fairly no yes I'm named after the
platform that we all know and love I'm a
senior at the University of Cincinnati
in Ohio and previously I've held
internships at Microsoft and Mozilla
working out in Firefox and I'm gonna be
doing a final internship at Google in
Japan actually working on chromium and
the web platform so currently I'm a
chromium committer which is basically
fancy speak for someone who has write
access and you can approve certain stuff
and I'm also what working group
standards out of error so if you don't
know what that last one is that's that's
primarily what we're gonna be talking
about today aside from that you can
follow me on twitter and check out my
work on github and feel free to email me
anytime you know during or after the
talk Dom my crummy org there's any
questions about getting involved in the
web platform at web standards and
browsers stuff in general so I want to
talk about what this talk actually is I
kind of had three overarching goals that
I wanted to reach when working on this
talk and the first one is just provide a
background in history and two web
standards and some of the organizations
that are responsible for their
governance and and their authorship this
could really be an its own talk but I
know we didn't come here for a history
lesson so I'm just gonna give a brief
brief history on this to kind of set the
stage next I want to talk about you know
as a web developer how can you actually
make use of a web standard right a lot
of us go to mdn or Google some API and
figure out how it works but I kind of
want to talk about the technical bits of
web standards and show how you can make
use of them and how to read them and how
to navigate that space finally I want to
talk about how you can get involved I
want to share a bit about my own story
of getting involved with web standards
and working on the web platform and
hopefully encourage some of you to do
the same so to kind of set the stage for
the talk I'd like to propose you know
the idea that we need a definition of a
standard now largely this depends on
context if we're going to define you
know on your word and so I'd like to
propose my own definition for the
purposes of this talk it's a little bit
wordy so bear with me a document
specifying observable effects of
Technology with multiple independent
implement
patience now it's kind of wordy like I
said so let's just focus on some key
points right we care about the
observable effects of technology what
are the side effects of it how if I run
something what does it do how does it
look and feel how can I actually use it
and and does it change depending on you
know where I'm where I'm using it from
and this last part is multiple
independent implementations technology
with multiple independent
implementations I think this is really
important and it's it's far from a new
concept in technology you know we've
seen this with like UNIX operating
systems for example I can kind of make
my own version of you know my own of
Linux distribution you can have your own
Linux distribution and and you get one
and you get one and everybody can have
their own you know separate distribution
with sugar on top of it but what I
really care about as a desktop app
developer if I were one is you know can
I write an application that works once
everywhere and no matter what operating
system I'm using for you know that's in
the UNIX family of os is that it's gonna
work you know uniformly so to kind of
make that environment conducive to that
you know interoperable behavior among
the different operating systems we've
had the set of plastic standards
developed to kind of unify this
observable behavior the same thing goes
for web tech and this is primarily what
I'm going to talk about today those II
these are not actually to scale though
but I happen to know for a fact that you
can't go to the store and you buy one
HTTP you know it's a protocol it's just
it's just an idea and it's something
that you can implement to kind of make
it compatible with other versions of
this this protocol and the same
basically goes for JavaScript as well
right we can run JavaScript in a bunch
of different places unlike maybe Python
it's kind of like we have one Python we
get from the Python people and that's
kind of it but with JavaScript I can run
it in Chrome I can run it in an edge on
the chakra engine and I can run it a
node in all kinds of different places
and the same goes for kind of the star
of the talk today which is the web
platform API so I've gone through a
career change I'm now no longer a UNIX
app developer but I'm a web developer
and so I need to know that the same
api's that exists in chrome also are
going to be there in Firefox and more
importantly that they're all going to
work the same and kind of function
uniformly that's really important
probably the biggest thing I learned
when making this slide is though that
keynote is really cool and has a bunch
of different goofy symbols that you can
use so I thought that that little dude
looked like a face so I dressed him up
given some underwear and a hat and stuff
like that so let's talk about where web
api's come from right this is important
we are
our web developers and we kind of want
to know where the stuff comes from and
how we can make more of them I
personally think the logical answer
probably is JavaScript right we use Web
API when we're using JavaScript for
example here's a snapshot of the chrome
dev tools and when I'm you know right I
can write things like a for loop and a
while loop but I can also fetch you know
super prominent websites on the internet
like that one and I can use set timeout
and all kinds of stuff like that so it
stands the reason that this kind of
stuff is part of the language now we
have to talk about what is the language
or what does JavaScript I'm just gonna
fly through this slide because we all
know the big story of Brendan I can he
created it in 10 days and whatever but
it's just a general-purpose programming
language that is created for the
purposes of the web I was plopped into
netscape 2.0 and that made it a really
interesting thing it made it a candidate
for Standardization because there was
going to be multiple independent
implementations of it and so we needed
some group that could come by and pick
up the task of standardizing and Ekman
did this they stand for the European
computer Manufacturers Association and
they created equi script and we've had
some success with this with the various
engines for example there's a bunch of
different implementations of the same
sort of technology you've probably seen
this list or something similar to it
before the standard looks something like
this it's really big it's really hard to
read but it's on github and it's hosted
under the tc39 s github page tc39 just
stands for technical committee 39 so
when we're writing the standard writing
ACMA script how does it work right what
are we gonna put in the standard we're
making a new language so we have to make
it make it really general so we need a
really strict separation of concerns
between all the contents and the
standards in the standard we just need
to be dealing with the language syntax
and the semantics and some of the
constructs and the primitives and that's
a true scripting language it should be
able to be plopped into any host
environment but the language itself
shouldn't actually have to know anything
explicit about that environment now
we're really used to using that language
in a web browser so we're used to web
api's and stuff like that but the
language itself doesn't actually know
about those things so web api is not
part of the ACMA script language or the
door javascript language they're
effectively mix-ins and they're baked in
the browsers and browsers can support
basically a version of echo script as
their JavaScript engine and a bunch of
web api is that we can use that kind of
tag-along alongside this version drachma
script that kind of interplay with it
and so we have hakama right they're
responsible for and tc39 are responsible
for standardizing ACMA script and
javascript that we all know and love so
who's responsible for standardizing the
web api so we've kind of heard a little
bit about this today from some of the
talks there's two big groups right now
that are responsible for this primarily
you've probably seen at least one of
these logos before we have the w3c and
the what working group and the what
working group denoted by the question
mark on the right is what I'm gonna be
talking about primarily today this is
the organization I told you all that I
was a part of at the beginning so the
what working group stands it's just an
acronym
unfortunately so it stands for a long
string of text that kind of summarizes
what we do it was formed in 2004 after a
w3c workshop basically they decided to
kind of branch off from the w3c and
create their own canonical standards
that specify the web platform so they
have an HTML standard which kind of
defines the HTML language and the parser
and the event loop and a lot of the it's
basically the kitchen sink of the web
platform is actually what it calls
itself to and they have you know they
specified the Dom API is the interface
that we use to talk to the web and and
some networking primitives like fetch
and streams and a lot of really cool
things like notifications and primitives
but how are these things actually
written right if we're gonna write a
browser and we want to write ACMA script
you know we start with the JavaScript
engine okay now if we read the ACMA
scripts back there's a lot of stuff in
there
but there's also a bunch of exposed
objects that would get for free and
JavaScript we get things like the array
constructor and you know data objects
and week maps and all kinds of data
structures that are natively exposed to
recomm scripts but we want our browser
to be a little more powerful you know we
wanted to have me the Dom so we give it
you know a document object we can add a
couple more paragraphs onto the end and
give it a query selector method and
we've kind of extended our language a
little bit more the documents getting
bigger but it's getting more powerful so
we also would love to to you know
contact the network as well so we'll
give it some networking primitives
things like fetch things like requests
and it'd be really cool if we could do
ourselves a good service and debug our
code so we'll maybe give it a console
object as well a bunch of methods on top
of that this is one way to write it just
keep appending text on to the same
to the same massive documents but it's
going to get pretty lengthy and
unmaintainable so the what working group
maintains separate standards for each of
these kind of ideas that have a
separation of concerns and each standard
is responsible for talking about how
they enter leave with the other
specifications and the web as well as
echinus script and things like that and
as a result we get web api's alongside
echo script and JavaScript now if we
want to read these web api's as web
dollars as web developers we want to
make use of them we need to kind of know
the anatomy of a standard we need to
know what is actually in these documents
because it's kind of a mystical thing in
mystical process and and it's actually
really you know not too difficult to get
involved and it's it's all very open and
happening right under right under our
noses so I was thinking about this a lot
for this talk and I kind of came to the
conclusion that there are two big parts
of standards to kind of be aware of the
first is algorithms so I don't know
about you guys I love algorithms spend
many an evening as it were working on
leet code and hacker rank stuff and I
really like algorithms and data
structures stuff I think that kind of
theory computation is really really cool
algorithms are really just a set of
steps to perform a task so let's go
ahead and take a look at an algorithm
inside a web standard right we have the
console standard and there's a bunch of
different methods on there if you
haven't heard of it there's one called
console count and here's the algorithm
specified in the standard there's five
steps that run every time you invoke
console count there's a couple that we
really care about for the purposes of
this talk though you can see we're given
something called a label and basically
the idea of this algorithm is if we've
seen this label before when we call this
in this function then you know increment
some number that we have that we have
associated with label otherwise we can
set it to one this is the algorithm and
then eventually we want to just print it
to the screen this longer thing is just
abstract text for saying hey browser you
know show this to the user in whatever
way you see fit this is nice because I
kids the web developer I could come in
here check out the algorithm and it
answers a couple questions for me like
you know what is the initial value of
the number that is associated with the
label and what happens every time I call
it and what can I expect and so we can
read the algorithm and kind of
understand what's going on now the
second important thing about specifying
and using web api is understanding the
look in the fee
so I think that's really important
what's it mean for an API to have a look
and feel so I thought of this and I
think it's kind of like you know what's
it mean to to use the API as a developer
what's it called where is it hanging off
of some other object is it just globally
exposed does it take anything is there
you know a bunch of parameters how many
parameters does it return anything this
stuff is really important for us to know
and a lot of us who are used to going to
mdn and maybe googling this kind of
stuff to find it but I also want to show
that you can just go to the standard so
here's another part of the console
standard to that the what working group
maintains it's a big scary block of text
but let's focus on the bit that's
complementary to what we were talking
about before the count method so we have
this right this kind of can tell you a
little bit about it right okay so it's
called count it exists under the console
namespace so console that count that
kind of makes sense how I would use it
it's of type void so I probably
shouldn't expect to get anything from it
just not gonna really return anything
but I might do stuff and it takes in a
single parameter called label it's
optional and it's type is Dom string so
we don't know what Dom string is right
now but let's just assume it's just a
regular string that gives us some some
cool information it's pretty expressive
but it's not JavaScript because we care
about types and and it's not C++ because
we see other invalid things going on
around here so what exactly is this
language it's called web IDL in a sense
for web interface definition language
and you'll see it in a lot of
specifications and it kind of forms a
contract for this basically the
signature of Web API is that you use and
that contract protects the algorithm
because when I go into the algorithm and
I'm running these steps I want to be
able to know what label is I needed you
know maybe I'm making some assumptions
that it's a string and I'm operating it
on that accordingly and that's really
important for me to know and so I want
to talk about how web IDL actually works
in practice okay so your while ejs dev
you got your Viking hat on and you
really care about types right so you're
gonna call you're gonna match on your
keyboard and called console count and
you're gonna just give it whatever you
what you can give it a symbol or you can
give it an object you can get whatever
but the second you do that the web IDL
sheriff is gonna stick in it's gonna
come in and it's basically gonna be like
hold up hold up hold up hold up you
called console count
and you can give it whatever you want
right symbol if you want it to be so
inclined to do so you have a number
whatever but I'm gonna make sure that
you know this contract is obeyed
I'm expecting a Dom string and I'm gonna
make sure that whatever you give me can
pass as a Dom string and if it does
that's cool we go to the algorithm
continue with a hopefully successful
call and and keep going but just like a
sheriff can throw someone to jail that
web by DL Sheriff so to speak can throw
a type error resulting you in with you
in code Jail it's probably the worst
place to be right you're staring at the
terminal or sorry the dev tools and you
got all this red scary text around you
don't know what's going on so we want to
stay away from that now real sheriffs in
the real world know who to arrest who
not to arrest stuff like that that's
that's really important something part
of their job so they kind of basically
have a rule book of things to follow
here and just like they're the real
sheriff central rule book the web IDL
Sheriff has a rule book in the form of
the web IDL standard and it basically
defines a lot of the stuff that that
it's supposed to be enforcing so we saw
an example of conversion here's a
snippet from the web IDL standard that
basically is responsible for converting
a Tekamah script value to what is called
a Dom string something that the web IDL
has defined basically the meat of this
algorithm is just to kind of delegate to
step two and call this two string thing
this is an abstract operation defined in
the ACMA script standard so we're just
kind of passing through right to the
ACMA scripts back and we could of course
write to string everywhere we needed to
instead of using web IDL but yeah this
is really nice because it's pretty
expressive it tells us tells us how
things should work in a really normative
clear way and if your techs are outgoing
when I get to here I can know that I'm
working on a string and that things have
been accepted in the sheriff is ok with
it so why are we using this thing called
web IDL anyways right what exactly is it
so it's it's just an abstraction of
Rackham script text as you saw step two
was we just kind of delegate to the echo
script standard it's two string thing it
does a lot of things for us though it
helps us write a lot with just a few
words potentially it takes care of a lot
of like type conversions we saw a really
simple example of a type conversion but
you can imagine perhaps a much more
complicated one and we would want to
repeat all those steps to you know it's
convert things and then kind of make our
assumptions everywhere we needed to in
the spec so we can use web
to kind of just abstract that stuff away
it also takes care of things like
property initialization for us and other
stuff like that it also helps us define
where our interfaces are exposed in a
really expressive way like we like we
saw but I think the most important thing
about web IDL personally is that you
don't actually have to use it it's as
line1 suggests just an abstraction over
equina scripts of the ACMA script text
and that's really important because we
have some standards that are written
without web IDL and that's totally valid
it just kind of speaks within the same
language of the equi script it's
standard space in that uses the same
verbage and the same sort of stuff but
web by DL is just a nice way to be
succinct and kind of foster
interoperability on the platform so you
can always feel free to you know
hopefully that that little foray into
web IDL makes you a little bit more
comfortable reading some of the
standards that they that they come with
in so finally I want to talk about how I
got involved in this and how and how you
can do the same and hopefully motivate
you to do the same as well so who knows
this logo let's get raised
show of hands right hey a lot of people
cool so this is the angular logo this
flat designer believe is new since
angular 2 and basically a couple years
ago I was like yeah I'm gonna start like
given more stuff with web applications
so I better learn a big heavy framework
that I can bog me down and figure out
how to write all this stuff and so
angular 2 at the time was an alpha
there's a basically mess right things
were always moving around and I would
always hear people say yeah you know
angular angular is getting a you know a
new router or angular is getting a new
object or new this kind of stuff and it
was really easy to track the progress of
this it was happening on github I knew
some of the people working on it so you
could always just kind of dig around at
the same time I heard another camp of
people kind of talking about JavaScript
there they were saying you know hey
javascript is getting you know async
iterators or you know did you know about
custom elements can you figure out how
to use those and I was like well that's
interesting cuz that's not really
angular specific so I was really
interested in digging around figuring
out who's deciding this stuff because
like like how does this work I would
kind of wanna be a part of it seems
pretty cool we're evolving the platform
so eventually it came across this guy's
profile his name is Dominic Nicola and I
just learned recently that he was
actually a speaker at the first Cascadia
j/s in 2012 it's true that we both have
the same
that's pretty cool and so I reached out
to him I was like hey I see you you know
you're working on you know what working
groups 'but standards and all that stuff
like that big contributor to the tc39
proposals and so i had reached out i was
like hey what do you do really and how
can i do it - it seems kind of cool are
you actually paid to work on this stuff
it's it's pretty cool and so he was
basically like hey you know we both have
the same name we're both Dom's right and
then working on the platform so I'll let
you in on some secrets and the biggest
the biggest piece of advice here is
probably to dig around on some of the
what working group standards and
actually just take a look at some issues
there's a lot of issue labels that the
issues are kind of affixed with one of
them is good first issue and basically
as the name implies they are good first
issues for people to get involved in and
a lot of them are low-hanging fruit or
some of them are editorial in nature
that you can just kind of go in and dig
around in a web standard and figure out
how to work with them I want to cut away
though from keynote and probably screw a
lot of things up in the process but
let's see if I can just show what the
what working groups page looks like do
we have it yes okay
now if I can figure out where my mouse
is I would also be cool one second all
right cool so so here's here's the what
working groups github page basically
just to kind of show you you know it's
all open it's all happening right in
front of you and it's a very welcoming
area you're allowed inside basically
this is this was basically just a list
of all the specifications that we
maintains giant list of the HTML
standard the fetch standard and stuff
like that and so we can always just go
to the one of these repositories
and see what's inside right there must
be some sort of source code that the
standard is you know existed and that
it's written in and a lot of times this
will take form in a take in the form of
a BS file so bs does not stand for
we're actually very serious
people here we're working on standards
right we're on the platform so bs since
our bike shed and it's basically this
language that we kind of mix in with
with HTML and and pre-process before we
build a standard it kind of helps us
with cross-linking and some other fancy
things it's pretty easy to get the hang
of we could check out the source there
all the standards exist out
spec or you know something dot spec org
and basically they look like this
they're the ones with the green logos
that the browser is actually trust and
so we go in yeah we can check out the
standard all kinds of stuff like that
and more portly if you're looking to get
involved you can go onto the issues
section here and we have a bunch of
different labels that we use that's not
where I'd want to go so yeah if we want
to check out these issues this for
example this is the fetch standard where
things like the fetch method exist and
the request object and stuff we could go
in and try to find the good first issues
and be like oh yeah this is really cool
right
I can I can dig around here and maybe
help outs on some issues and so now
we're kind of on to evolving the web
platform right we're working with a
standards body to help fix some of the
problems that they've identified and the
platform is so this kind of this kind of
goes back to interfacing with the
community and the community groups
online so I want to talk a little bit
about this when dealing with the what
working group there's a bunch of
different ways to communicate with us
we're always on get up of course you can
you know chime in on an issue and be
like hey I really want to work on this
this this looks really cool I think it's
interesting
we're always super super happy to
provide mentoring mentorship for people
that are looking to get involved also
we're on the really big bad scary place
that is IRC we're in the free no under
three node on the web working group
Channel I'm always logged in a lot of us
a lot of the editors always logged in so
we're always available to to also help
with questions and stuff like that
there's a lot of information here that
have thrown at you and things like that
and at the very end of the under
presentation I'll kind of give you with
a well one web page that you can go to
kind of get a lot of this stuff from but
I want to talk about why to do this
anyways right there's a lot of cool ways
to read to learn reasons to learn
angular until I react and to work on the
web but I think what's really cool is is
you know I know we're in Seattle and
Microsoft Land basically but if you have
a problem with some Windows api's
basically you kind of have to work in
Microsoft to get them fixed or changed
or do something like that but what the
web platform all this stuff is happening
right in front of your face it's all in
github it's all free to participate and
you know anybody anybody can do it and
just go on and start working on stuff
and I think that's really really cool
web developers are in a really unique
position of being able to influence and
modify the platform that we all develop
on every single day and that's really
exciting to me and
one of the reasons that I got involved
so I want to leave you with a repository
that I just kind of started the other
day now is the time to take pictures of
the slides if you're interested in
getting involved there's a lot of
information there's a lot more
information beyond just what I've
covered in this talk so check out the
Cascadia jeaious repository that i
maintain on github it's just kind of got
some getting started information and so
the links to other talks that people
have done on similar stuff and how to
get involved in the web community and
modify web standards and stuff like that
finally I want to leave you with some of
the things that I've worked on so
hopefully hopefully provide some
motivation to show that you guys that
you all can do the same recently I've
changed how fetch works the fetch API
I've worked on Chrome to basically
modify when we said credential when we
send credentials when we make a request
stuff like that basically did the same
for for module scripts and took part in
some of the standardization work for
there so that required of course talking
to a bunch of the browsers and saying
hey you know we're thinking about making
this change it kind of makes sense what
do you guys think and can I do it
I also standardized and implemented the
referrer policy attribute this is
security even private security privacy
attribute in HTML so I did this on the
script elementary simply so I like
resource loading and then security
privacy kind of stuff I've also
implemented a bunch of console API eyes
so the console standard I mentioned is a
really really good one to start getting
involved with so I encourage you to
check it out it's what I started with
and I also started working on Chrome
partially as a result of that
finally I've been working on something
called priority hints which is just a
new resource living API that kind of
lets developers tell the browser what
priority they would like to be
associated with a request it's a new
standard and so we're digging through
that I did the implementation work in
Chrome and so we're just kind of doing
some experimentation to see if it's
going to be able to pull its own weight
but other than that I hope I've left you
with a good taste in your mouth and when
it comes to web standards and I hope
that you all you know feel motivated to
get involved and contribute back to the
platform
thanks a lot that's it
[Applause]